When I'm starting from exp, I can use any of these 3 rules,
so in particular I could use the third one and just replace exp with number,
so number is definitely in the language of the grammar.
It's one of the strings that I can derive.
Unfortunately, - number is not.
There's no way to get a minus sign without an exp before it.
If we take a look at all 3 of our rules, the minus sign only appears once,
and there's something before it, so this isn't going to happen.
Over here, number + number + number,
it looks pretty big, but I could get it by applying this first rewrite rule twice
and then turning each one of these expressions into numbers.
I've drawn it in kind of this tree format.
We will see more on that in a minute, but for now, just imagine I did this
because I ran out of space in the corner.
Poor planning on my part.
Similarly, we could get number - number + number
just by getting a minus sign here instead, using rule 2 and rule 1 in combination.
Over here, there's no way to get number next to number.
Whenever we get multiple expressions on the right-hand side,
they're always separated by a terminal.
This can't happen, so just to review,
this uses rule 1, rule 2, and rule 3 three times.
This is rule 1. That's rule 2.
That's rule 3 three times in order to derive this string.